sie wollte angeblich kindern in syrien
helfen und ging zu isis ja das ist die
unglaubliche geschichte der 26-jährigen
der in einer bildreportage erzählt sie
wie sie zu isis ging wie sie die zeit in
syrien erlebt hat und wie sie nach drei
jahren zurück nach deutschland kam
meine erste leicht ich gesehen hab das
war nach 23 monaten
ich fand das nicht schlimm ich finde das
jetzt auch nicht schlimm aber ich fand
es interessant wie das aussieht
[Musik]
als ich mal wir das erste mal gesehen
habe mit seiner waffe und am ganzen
militär angezogen was wenn wir sind
jetzt die bild-reporter eine pauli und
türen stritzel ihr habt derya von juni
bis november 2008 10 mit der kamera
begleitet und daraus entstand dann diese
fünfteilige videoreportage die ja viele
diskussionen ausgelöst hat was war das
besondere und auch das polarisierende an
dieser geschichte also das besondere an
der geschichte war das eine geschichte
zu erzählen hatte oder auch erzählte
hand die einfach einzigartig war in der
art und weise wie sie es erzählt hat
also dass jemand überhaupt so offen und
frei darüber spricht offen auch im sinne
von nicht verhüllt da kannst du dich
auch ganz gut aus und weiß das ist
glaube ich international auch noch nicht
vorher gab oder also es gibt nur ganz
wenige ganz wenige fälle in denen
rückkehrer tatsächlich so offen sprechen
im sinne von wie anders gesagt hat nicht
verhüllt also sprich die sind sprechen
mit ihrem gesicht in die kamera werden
nicht verpixelt werden nicht wenn nicht
verfremdet und sie hat ja auch keiner
zweiten weise unverhüllt gesprochen
nämlich dass sie hier ein relativ klar
geschildert hat was sie dort erlebt hat
was sie dort gemacht hat was sie da
widerfahren ist und besonders wahrheit
oder ist an ihr halt auch dass sie
überhaupt nicht dass also wenn wenn man
liest eine isis rückkehrerin erzählt und
dann sieht man sie sie ist überhaupt
nicht das was man erwartet also rein
optisch schon ist es nicht das was man
sich wahrscheinlich eigentlich
vorgestellt hat ich habe immer gesagt
nach hinweisen auf die geschichte auch
angesprochen worden bin dass ich also
wenn man so eine geschichte als fiction
geschichte erzählt hätte und die man
hätte carsten müssen und sie beim
casting gewesen wäre hätte man gesagt
die kölner nicht nehmen die zu krass wie
die mega tätowiert und überhaupt das ist
einfach auch nicht wirklich eine eine
wirklich einzigartige und
ganz spezielle person auch und das kommt
in der fünfteiligen doku und auch im
trailer ganz bewusst auch so vor dass an
ihr so besonders ist dass sie einerseits
sehr offen und cool ja auch erzählt und
man merkt auch dass wir sachen dass sie
weiß wenn ich das jetzt sage dann finden
die das gras aber dass sie auf der
anderen seite auch total emotionale
momente hatte also wo man gemerkt hat
bei bestimmten fragen die wir gestellt
haben dass sie da noch mal eigentlich
sich gerade zurück erinnert dass ihr die
tränen kommen und auch das ist glaube
ich weiß was man nicht erwartet hat oder
was man nicht erwarten würde als
zuschauer mann war auch immer in mir war
selbst nicht so ganz klar ist jetzt
verunsichert oder ist das ein bisschen
posen und kokettieren damit also und so
ging es mir bis zum ende der
dreharbeiten auch dass ich sie
eigentlich nicht komplett für mich
einschätzen kann und einsortieren kann
das ist ja eigentlich hast du eine große
ambivalenz noch nicht so einerseits
kokettiert sie damit ja dann merkt man
mitunter dass sie da das erst mal
anfängt überhaupt dazu reflektieren
während er vor der kamera spricht was
sie ja was sie da erlebt hat was sie da
gemacht hat damit sie sich auch selber
schuldig gemacht hat wenn es eine sache
gibt die der dir da es erst mal so ins
bewusstsein rücken
also auch als journalist man ist es ja
natürlich gewohnt dass leute emotional
sind oder vielleicht auch mal weinen
aber gerade wenn jemand weint dann kommt
er dieser mensch auch na also man hat
kein mitleid man ist traurig das ist
natürlich bei jemand der in so eine
geschichte mit sich bringt auch in sich
selbst ist man dann so ein bisschen
ambivalent und hin- und hergerissen weil
man nicht so richtig was soll man denn
jetzt von der halten die sagt er ganz
krasse sachen und zehn minuten später
weint sie deswegen das ist schon also
war auf jeden fall als protagonistin
oder gegenüber definitiv etwas anderes
der kontakt ist durch dich entstanden
führen zu ihr und zu der geschichte wie
kam es genau dazu genau also ich hatte
ich hatte über ihren mann damals
geschrieben 2016
es hätte einen konvertiten kennengelernt
im internet ist sie dann aus ihrer stadt
im ruhrgebiet gefolgt nach syrien hat
sich da
ja nicht hin locken lassen ist
vielleicht zu harmlos sind aber sie
wollte dort schon hin hat ihn geheiratet
erst dann von dieses getötet wurden nach
nach einigen monaten und ihrer mutter
wurde seiner mutter wurde die geschichte
dann so verkauft
dass er bei einem luftangriff gestorben
sein ich hatte dann gehört dass er
tatsächlich von ihr selber getötet
wurden sei habe darüber dann mit der
mutter und ihre schwiegermutter
sozusagen darüber gesprochen hat das in
artikel form gebracht das kann dann auch
in der zeitung woraufhin sie sich dann
bei mir gemeldet hat und den kontakt
haben wir dann eigentlich im prinzip die
ganze zeit gehalten
wie schwierig war es denn für euch beide
der ja für diese geschichte zu gewinnen
sie hat sich initiativ gemeldet hat hat
sich dann aus als sie dann später in
deutschland war auch noch mal bei mir
gemeldet und meinte ob wir da nicht mal
was machen wollen sie wollte ihre
geschichte erzählen
unter anderem hat ihn aus der motivation
heraus dass sie eine große lücke im
lebenslauf hat die sie in allen
kontakten ist es im leben habt ihr sie
ein bisschen ein bisschen intensiver
sind die sie nicht recht erklären kann
und sie wollte damit dann offensiv an
die an die öffentlichkeit gehen und das
eben auch so so klar stellen eine frage
die heftig in den sozialen medien
diskutiert wurde war
warum geben wir einer isis rückkehr in
eine plattform und warum zeigen wir in
der doku auch dieses propagandamaterial
was könnte dazu sagen wonach wurde das
entschieden
an allererster stelle steht einfach
journalistisches interesse und ich
glaube das ist schon warum wir eine
plattform eine bühne geben wenn man das
so ausdrücken möchte was er da schwingt
ja was negatives mit
aber das interesse an der doku war so
riesig auch deshalb machen wir heute
dieser diese fragerunde dass ich allein
damit schon glaube ich die frage werde
ich ja übrig aber damit schon ganz gut
beantwortet es gibt einfach ein
interesse daran an den personen die als
rückkehrer die sich nach
terrororganisationen am neuen aus lang
geschlossen haben und wieder herkommen
und die leute möchten natürlich wissen
wer ist denn das also wer kommt zurück
was sind das für leute was haben die für
biografien das haben die vielleicht auch
für brüche in ihrem leben was hat sie
motiviert da hinzugehen und es ist ja
nicht so dass wir sie dass wir sie
einfach nur reden lassen sondern
tatsächlich wird es ja auch eingeordnet
von den experten mitunter auch die
sachen die sachen naja kritisch
hinterfragen und man muss ja auch sagen
also man kann sagen man kann sich fragen
warum geben wir diese plattform eine
plattform hätte sie bekommen wenn sie
alles was sie sagen möchte einfach frei
raus hätte sein können und wir hätten es
zwei stunden einfach oder in sechs
teilen einfach 1 1 gesendet es war aber
relativ schnell auch klar dass natürlich
der terrorismus experte peter neumann
definitiv auch ganz viel dazu sagen wird
und auch der psychologe der welt hilft
sie einzuordnen und zu verstehen
deswegen auch zum thema
propagandamaterial also sie schilder der
ihre durchaus subjektive wahrnehmung von
isis und wie es dort war und deswegen
ist natürlich auch videomaterial drin
was ist es uns verkaufen wollte wie es
dort alles das doch alles ganz normal
ist das ist ihre subjektive welt und
deswegen haben wir natürlich auch
entschieden dass wir durchaus die
gräueltaten dieses auch verübt hat auch
zeigen müssen um halt eben ein gegensatz
zu dem zu haben was ihre wahrnehmungs
oder wie wie sie es zum teil ja auch
gesehen hat haben uns aber dabei
entschieden die ganz schrecklichen
szenen natürlich raus zu nehmen hat der
real geld für die teilnahme an der doku
bekommen was sie hat er geht für
fahrtkosten und eine
fahrtkostenerstattung bekommen sie war
zwei mal zwei mal zwei mal in berlin wo
hier gedreht haben und da wurde dann die
fahrtkosten erstattet ansonsten kein
geld bekommen sie hat auch nicht danach
gefragt also dass jetzt das wäre für uns
auch nicht fahrbar gewesen also
verstörend ist die geschichte allemal
also der revolte nach syrien um kindern
zu helfen und sie ging zu hieß es
wie geht das also ist das dumm ist das
naiv unwissens wie kann man sich das
erklären
also ich hab es ja vorhin schon so ein
bisschen angedeutet ich glaube dass das
das hast du so halb geglaubter glaube
ist von ihr selber dass sie das selber
so für sich vor sich so als
rechtfertigung benutzt hat um dahin zu
gehen sie es aus relativ schwierigen
umfeld in der doku wird ja auch ihre
freundin erzählt das ja auch dass sie
sich hier als davor möglich menü
gearbeitet hat mit ihrem mit ihrem
ex-freund relativ hoch an den hells
angel der sie durchaus schlecht
behandelt hat und sie das quasi als
ausflucht mehr oder weniger genutzt hat
sich nach söhne abzusetzen ist natürlich
die frage inwieweit da noch andere
motive eine rolle gespielt haben aber
ich glaube dieses was sie da so sagte
dies ist als juristisch ich wollte da
nur kindern helfen
also da da würde ich sagen das hat
vielleicht allenfalls eine
untergeordnete rolle gespielt dieser
dieser wunsch stehen sie da äußert oder
diese nicht der wunsch falsch
die die absicht diese da angeblich hätte
kindern zu helfen die ist natürlich
fraglich also das kann sein dass das mit
reingespielt hat das eine rolle gespielt
hat kindern zu helfen in syrien bei dem
wunsch dahin zu gehen dass man das vor
sich selbst vielleicht recht fertig
damit
aber es gibt ganz viele orte auf der
welt an denen man kinder helfen kindern
helfen kann auch in syrien gibt es sehr
viele orte von kindern helfen kann dafür
muss man nicht zum nächsten start gehen
und es ist natürlich auch für jeden
halbwegs erwachsenen menschen der seine
sinne beisammen hat war klar wohin die
reise geht wenn ich mich dort nach
syrien begeben
vielleicht nicht im kompletten umfang
aber es ist klar dass ich da zu einer
gruppe hinfahre die die register rigiden
moralvorstellungen umsetzt die
tugendterror im wirklich mit der
betonung auf terror ausübt und die ihre
gegner massakrieren ich nehme es
niemandem ab der sagt er wusste nicht
ganz bewusst überhaupt nicht wo es
hingeht vielleicht muss das nicht ganz
genau aber zumindest eine ahnung konnten
haben aber ich glaube das ist halt auch
da dieses gerufen hat dass sie da jemand
sein kann irgendwie auch 'ne taffe frau
ist das merken auch dass sie erzählt ich
bin als einzige frau da am hinrichtungs
platz gewesen also dieses dass sie so
anerkennung bekommt und das ist glaube
ich etwas was sie in deutschland einfach
perspektivisch nicht bekommt oder
bekommen hat und also das ist natürlich
völlig absurd aber ich glaube dass das
halt auch so eine seine motivation die
sie irgendwie dahin gezogen hat es wäre
mir auch wie sie damit kokettiert naja
darüber spricht so ich hab mir nicht
sagen lassen und ich habe also was der
psychologe hat auch noch mal ja sehr gut
einordnen man natürlich sagt dass das
vorkommen ist sich in ein solches system
zu begehen und begeben und sich dann
noch und dann dort noch gegen die regeln
zu verstoßen und das für sich selber
dann noch irgendwie als als mut zu
deklarieren
was es natürlich nicht ist dieses dass
sie dann damit kokettiert das zeigt aber
irgendwie ja dem die ist irgendwie auf
der suche nach nach identität nach
selbstbestätigung und sie hat dann
tatsächlich also ich habe es von
wirklich von von mehreren anderen frauen
die zeitgleich mit ihr dort waren
erfahren die alle gesagt haben was ist
eigentlich aus der geworden ist hat mich
alle gefragt die war immer so krass
drauf was ist er denn zuzutrauen also
wäre es auch denkbar dass sie menschen
getötet hat sie spricht er auch davon
dass sie gut schießen konnte hat waffen
unterricht bekommen ja was was hat sie
überhaupt in den drei jahren in syrien
alles gemacht
knopp ist relativ schwierig wenn man
wenn man jemandem einen längeren
zeitraum begleitet hat und glaubt die
person halbwegs zu kennen
und dann sagt ich würde mir nicht
zutrauen dass tatsächlich von meinem
subjektiven empfinden würde ich sagen
würde ich ihn nicht zu trauen als
jemanden umgebracht hat allerdings war
ich natürlich nicht dabei um das aber
gleich nochmal zu relativieren gibt es
auch keinen anklagepunkte sie ist ja
mittlerweile befinden sie sich ja in
u-haft gibt es keinerlei anklagepunkte
die darauf hindeuten dass sie sich an
irgendwelchen kriegsverbrechen beteiligt
hat die hinrichtung und dergleichen
beinhalten dass sie damit kokettiert mit
einer waffe geschossen hat das findet
man eigentlich bei fast jeder dieser
frauen also fast alle sind irgendwie
stolz darauf
es hat natürlich etwas was sie vorher
nicht kannten als in deutschland waren
die kinder hinkriegen da kann die hand
gedrückt die wicken paar kilogramm und
dann schließen sie damit erst
nein das ist natürlich auch ein
wahrscheinlich im nationalteam fördern
das als martin forderte das ereignis für
solche frauen aber dass sie da jetzt
tatsächlich selber gekämpft hat oder ja
sogar jemanden umgebracht hat also
erscheint eher fraglich also auch
eingedenk der rolle die die frauen da
eigentlich so spielen in dem system da
möchten diese an gilt das ist komplett
ausschließen kann also danke geht einem
schon durch den kopf oder man fragt sich
das kann aber man weiß das hat einfach
nicht und genau auf grund dessen dass
man sich auch über kennen gelernt hat
als mensch würde man eher sagen nee aber
trotzdem bleibt da im hinterkopf dass
man denkt ja meistens nicht auf wiesen
noch mal um das noch mal deutlich zu
machen und da die sicherheitsbehörden
darauf keinerlei hinweise haben und die
sind relativ gut darüber informiert was
sie dort gemacht hat ich glaube kann man
davon kann man davon ausgehen dass in
der regel kommen solche tötungsdelikte
schon ans licht was hat sie in den drei
jahren dort gemacht also was macht man
so als isis braut in syrien
deren möglichkeiten sich zu bewegen sind
relativ eingeschränkt zumal dann wenn
sie nicht mehr verheiratet sind in der
regel werden die dann im frauenhaus
gesperrt wo die dann unter ihresgleichen
sind was ja ich habe ja auch schon so
wirklich dann die hölle auf erden ist
aber die auch die verheirateten frauen
sind in der regel tatsächlich im
internet unterwegs gewesen also kann es
viele von denen gesprochen hat die in
den ganzen tag im internet ab die
wechseln entweder zwischen ihren eigenen
whatsapp gruppen mit denen sie sich
untereinander schreiben weil sie sich
halt mitunter her auch nicht
nicht aufgrund dieser eingeschränkten
beweglichkeit sie dürfen den mann nicht
oder zumindest nur ganz kurze strecken
zurücklegen spielen irgendwelche kenitra
spiele oder im reports oder keine ahnung
was oder und das ist dann der fall für
die ideologisierte personen die machen
propaganda für ist also das ist auch
eine rolle die nicht wenige frauen
übernommen haben
auch von den deutschen die eben dann
also propaganda propaganda kanäle
betreiben indem sie dann da das leben
verherrlichen oder zur ausreise aufrufen
also sowas gibt es auch aber dass nicht
die haupttätigkeiten also die
haushaltsführung die kindererziehung ja
und eben dann propaganda und ja dort ab
wie es einmal so schön einfach
abzustellen
also das ist etwas was was ganz viele
dort gemacht haben und es gibt auch
fälle in denen frauen gekämpft haben
wobei das eben tatsächlich er in der
endphase des sogenannten kalifats
stattgefunden hat in denen die frauen
dann auch mit der waffe an der front um
gelaufen sind und da ja wie effektiv
auch immer dann da geschossen haben das
war der entscheidende punkt an dem der
ja dann für sich entschieden hat ich
möchte zurück nach deutschland
sie ist das haben wir in der doku nicht
ganz erwähnt aber sie ist zwei mal nach
syrien sie waren sie ist von islamischer
staat geflohen
2016 ist dann in die türkei ist dabei
bei verwandten untergekommen und hat
sich da so missverstanden oder schlecht
aufgehoben oder so eine mischung aus
allem gefühlt dass sie wieder zurück
nach syrien gegangen ist allerdings
nicht ins gebiet ist sondern von anderen
islamistischen gruppierungen hat dann da
irgendwie ja in der nähe der grenze zur
türkei eine zeit lang gewohnt
und da hat sie dann ja so ein gewisser
gewisse zeit genutzt über ihr leben
nachzudenken und vor allem über ihr über
ihr kind dem sie dann doch eine andere
zukunft bieten wollte als als der in
syrien ein kriegsgebiet aufzuwachsen
dass ich glaube das war dann das
entscheidende
sie hat damals hat immer gesagt
eigentlich möchte sie nicht mehr zurück
nach deutschland
aber wenn sie daran denkt dass ihr kind
haben behütet aufwachsen könnte dann
wäre das vielleicht auch am besten die
bessere option und letztendlich hat sich
dann dafür entschieden in die türkei
zurück zu gehen wurden dann aber
festgenommen und dann auch wieder nach
deutschland abgeschoben also sie wurden
natürlich nach der abschiebung nach
deutschland zunächst von der polizei
befragt also ist nicht so dass es
irgendwie an den behörden vorbei
geschehen ist
also die sicherheitsbehörden hatten sie
schon auf dem schirm was war ihre
motivation bei der doku mitzumachen
also ihre motivation war vor allem dass
sie reinen tisch machen wollte dass sie
erzählen wollte was in diesen jahren in
diesen drei jahren die sie in
deutschland die sind nicht in
deutschland geschehen ist weil es etwas
ist worauf sie immer wieder angesprochen
wird sie hat unter sie hat unter dieses
gelebt sie hat sich da mehrfach in
wirklichen lebensgefahr gebracht sie
kennt die leute sie weiß wozu sie fähig
sind und sie
sie hat sich schon damals relativ wenig
sagen lassen von denen und umso weniger
lässt sie sich in deutschland davon den
einschüchtern
also dafür ist glaube ich nicht der typ
dass sie dass sie darum geht zurück
schreckt davor dass dies tatsächlich
ohne dass man soll jetzt nicht
verherrlichen klingen aber ich glaube
dass das was man so als tough bezeichnet
es war ihr ganz wichtig immer dass sie
nicht so rüber kommen möchte oder nicht
so sein will wie die andere rückkehrerin
die immer irgendwie entweder er hat
immer gesagt ein auf opfer machen also
die immer so tun als hätten also
entweder entweder total noch
ideologisiert waren oder sind oder her
ich konnte nichts machen so hat sie es
dann tatsächlich immer gesagt und ich
glaube er war ganz wichtig das einfach
ganz ganz klar auch um deutlich zu
machen wie das so abläuft ganz klar und
deutlich einblicke zu geben wenn sie das
immer genervt hat wie andere
rückkehrerinnen dann irgendwie im
fernsehen wenn sie überhaupt mal darüber
reden
und da ist ja auch darf und da nehme ich
brauchte eine stütze ich kann es einfach
auch so erzählen wie ich bin und so wie
ich hier wird und ihr hattet ja auch
zugang zum familiären und persönlichen
umfeld von der riaa das ist natürlich
auch sehr krass von solchen ereignissen
betroffen ich meine wenn das kind nach
syrien geht und sich dem es an schließt
dann macht das natürlich auch was mit
der kompletten familie und dem umfeld
es ist ja aber nicht immer so einfach an
das umfeld ranzukommen meistens fühlen
sich die familien auch nicht verstanden
kaum einer kann sich in die lage
reinversetzen wie habt ihr das geschafft
und wie habt ihr das umfeld von der iaa
lebt was ich hatte mit der
schwiegermutter mit der mit der hacke
schon länger kontakt weil ich damals wie
gesagt die den artikeln die geschichte
gemacht hatte über ihren über ihren sohn
der damals von gs getötet wurde und mit
der us mutter hatte ich kontakt
während sie in syrien war hatte sie sich
losgesagt hatte sie sich losgesagt von
allen von allen verwandten als sie das
zweite mal nach syrien gegangen ist sie
hat niemandem gesagt wo sie ist hat sich
aber wie gesagt bei mir gemeldet und ich
musste dann als einziger wo sie wo sie
gerade steckt und habe dann ihre mutter
kontaktiert weil die sich natürlich
große sorgen gemacht hat wo tochter und
enkeltochter und enkel sind und ich
konnte sie dann beruhigen dass die heute
am leben sind und dass sie sicher sind
insofern war da der kontakt zur mutter
schon hergestellt genau und die waren
dann auch relativ offen und ich glaube
die hatten auch die waren auch dankbar
dafür dass sie das sie erzählen konnten
wie sie ihn so ergangen ist oder so es
war so mein eindruck genau also das war
auch mein eindruck den ich sollte als
wir dann bei der schwiegermutter waren
wo er auf das doppel interview
entstanden ist also wo heike die
schwiegermutter und der iaea zusammen
nebeneinander sitzen da waren wir bei
heike zu hause in der wohnung aber auch
die ganze familie drumherum
und da hat man auch gemerkt dass halt
wir haben natürlich also in guten oder
ein rad auf jeden fall zu der familie
hat und dass da ein gewisses
vertrauensverhältnis ist bzw was auch
darauf unter anderem beruf das jahr
anhaltend aufgrund der erfahrungen mit
dem thema ist und was was mit isis
rückkehrern oder kämpfern oder familien
ist da auch jemand ist wo die leute sich
also zumindest verstanden fühlen also
werden kennt halt ganz viele geschichten
natürlich und ist deswegen halt für
angehörige die glaube ich wirklich nicht
viel einen menschen haben in ihrem
umfeld denen sie das so erzählen können
ohne dass die vom glauben abfallen sagen
oder sein glauben nicht oder einfach
nichts mit dem zu tun haben wollen und
ich glaube dadurch einen entsteht halt
auch in die sonne so eine verbindung
die natürlich auch dabei hilft ein
zugang zu haben und mir ging es so als
sich heike getroffen habe dass die
erstens ein sehr also warme und
herzlicher mensch ist auch im umgang mit
der iaea und da sie und das hatte mich
beruhigt durchaus differenziert und auch
kritisch ist gegenüber all dem oder
vielen was der er dort gemacht hat oder
dass sie überhaupt dort war es zeigt er
dass da auch ganz viel gesunder
menschenverstand auf jeden fall da ist
genau und mit der mutter oder mit der
mama von derya der merkt man natürlich
dass es eine mutter ist die einfach
leidet dass ihre tochter einfach dinge
tut die sie nicht verstehe die sind
nachvollziehen kann er wo sie glaube ich
auch gar nicht weiß wie sie damit
umgehen soll also ich glaube sie es zum
teil auch überfordert das hat man
natürlich gemerkt also weil sie da sehr
emotional ist und ich glaube also jede
mutter auf dieser welt ist traurig wenn
ihr kind im gefängnis sitzt und es ist
wahrscheinlich einfach auch es fällt uns
leicht darüber zu urteilen weil weil wir
haben kein kind was im gefängnis sitzt
und schreckliche dinge gemacht hat und
deswegen glaube ich neigt man ganz
schnell dazu bei der mutter vielleicht
auch zu sagen hat merkt es nicht aber es
ist einfach eine mutter die für dieses
ganz ganz alles ganz schwer ist und die
hat glaube ich auch fast niemanden mit
dem sie sich darüber so austauschen kann
ein bisschen überrascht war ich als ich
in der doku gesehen habe als so einen
personalbogen von mario eingeblendet
wurde also hat ist es so eine art
personalstelle oder wie kann ich mir das
vorstellen
der institutionalisierte bürokratie da
ist da wird jeder erfasst der dort als
neuer kämpfer aus dem ausland kommt der
kann dann verschiedene sachen eintragen
bzw wird verschiedene sachen abgefragt
geburtsdatum geburtsort bestimmte
fähigkeiten seiner ausbildung
welche länder er schon bereist hat ob er
schon erfahrungen im jihad hat welche
verwendung er
welche verwendung mehr haben möchte also
ob er als selbstmordattentäter sterben
möchte ob er kämpfer sein möchte und
dergleichen auch kontaktmöglichkeiten zu
angehörigen alles so was wird in diesem
personal bögen erfasst ist einfach auch
darauf zurückzuführen dass das bei mir
erst in den höheren ebenen also in den
tatsächlichen entscheidungsebenen sehr
viele sehr viele leute aus früheren
irakischen geheimdienstkreisen unterwegs
sind die also aus der armee und aus dem
geheimdienst saddam hussein stammen die
sich mit einer solchen bürokratie sehr
gut auskennen die genau wissen wie man
ja wie man einen staat und wie man vor
allem ein geheimdienst und eine macht
und unterdrückungsapparat der immer nur
bürokratie benötigt wie man sowas
organisiert was in dann mitunter eben
auch zum zum nachteil zum nachteil wurde
weil diese bürokratie natürlich auch
dafür sorgt dass mitunter im
kriegsgebiet das sehr sehr dynamisch da
verschieben sich immer mal die fronten
und ende 2015 anfang 2016 haben dann
syrische wählen die damals sehr massiv
gegen ihr es gekämpft haben viele
solcher dokumente erbeutet und genau
darüber sind die dann auch zu uns
gelangt wie kann es denn sein dass ein
vermutliches dieses mitglied nach
deutschland wieder zurückkommen darf und
sich dann auch erstmal frei bewegen darf
weil es hat ein bisschen gedauert bis
sie dann letztendlich in u haft genommen
wurde
also genau dass sie zurückkehren kann er
deutschland sie ist ja deutsche
staatsbürgerinnen das kann niemand
verwehren also egal was sie gemacht hat
man kann ein deutscher staatsbürger
verwehren nach deutschland zu kommen was
danach passiert ist mitnehmen ist die
andere frage wenn es ein haftbefehl gibt
wird er festgenommen
den gab es in ihrem fall noch nicht sie
wurde allerdings bei der einreise
befragt von polizisten für ich glaube
zwei stunden meinte sie und natürlich
wussten die sicherheitsbehörden wer da
kommt
und natürlich hatten sie auch immer auch
auf dem schirm also
ihre wohnung wurde mehrfach karatschi
sind die natürlich in größerer man
stärker und mit mit gezogener waffe rein
und haben daraus durchaus auch mal
bedeutet dass man sich auf dem auf dem
schirm hat handys dann eingesammelt und
dergleichen ist natürlich so dass die
dass die behörden auch weiter ermitteln
dass sie natürlich sachen zusammentragen
und das dauert mitunter seine zeit und
bei ihr hat seit fast ein jahr lang
gedauert bis sie dann eben bisher neben
festgenommen wurde
wenn sie jetzt seit november 2008 10 in
u-haft sitzt wer kümmert sich aktuell um
ihren sohn also ist dabei bei ihrer
mutter oder als minister das war auch
also eine der meist gestellten fragen
was ist eigentlich mit ebenso und also
der sohn lebt bei ihrer mutter genau und
die kümmert sich jetzt erst mal und ab
wann ist man eigentlich ein mutmaßliches
mitglied einer terror-organisation das
ist speziell bei den frauen nicht ganz
so einfach nachts nachzuweisen und für
die für die den völkern manchmal nicht
ganz so einfach nachzuvollziehen dass
leute die dort waren die nachweislich
dort waren die nachweislich im
herrschaftsgebiet des islamischen
staates befunden haben
die daraus auch keinen hehl machen dass
die nicht unmittelbar angeklagt werden
können dass es deshalb der die
schwierigkeit besteht darin dass
nachgewiesen werden muss eine
unterstützungs handlung um eben diese
mitgliedschaft in der terrororganisation
zweifelsfrei zweifelsfrei nachzuweisen
also momentan ist es so dass die
bundesanwaltschaft bei der staatsschutz
sachen verhandelt werden worunter
terrorismus fällt die versuchen momentan
den frauen das dergestalt nach
zu weisen dass sie sagen sie sind in
häuser eingezogen werden sie dort gelebt
haben in der ak muss oder in anderen
städten in denen sich zuvor andere
nämlich die öffentlichen anwohner irak
oder syrer befunden haben die dann beim
vormarsch von iss fliegen mussten
und mit dadurch dass diese häuser
besetzt haben oder sich der einquartiert
haben ansehen kriegsverbrechen begangen
nämlich plünderung und darüber wird dann
sozusagen die ja so ein bisschen die
idee der bogen geschlagen zur
mitgliedschaft bei mir ist das wird man
schauen ob das dann halt bisher ist noch
niemand
nach dieser nach dieser konstruktion
verurteilt wurden ob das sozusagen auch
bei ihr der fall sein wird muss man
abwarten welche strafen gibt es denn für
die mitgliedschaft einer terror
organisation und das könnte das im fall
von derya dann bedeuten also die
höchststrafe ist für mitgliedschaft nach
129 18 jahre die wurde meines wissens
aber bei den ds leuten wurde die bei den
deutschen die erste kehren würde ich
noch nicht ausgereizt
dass deshalb der fall weil das natürlich
für die extremsten felder reserviert ist
also bei leuten die in die
kommandostrukturen eingebunden waren die
diese hat man mal wenn man ihnen andere
sachen nicht nachweisen kann die aber
sich sich an verbrechen der gruppe
wirklich ja federführend beteiligt haben
und nicht eben nur nach nicht eben nur
als als einfaches einfaches mitglied
dort waren bei der wir ja würde ich
zumindest nach meinem kenntnisstand auch
glauben dass sie da er so in die in die
kategorie d
mitläufer fällt also wenn sie nach 129a
b verurteilt würde ohne dass wir es
natürlich den genauen kenntnisstand der
behörden wissen aber kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das strafmaß sei
ausgereizt wird
wie war es überhaupt mit ihr
zusammenzuarbeiten
also sie war das also termine und
absprachen auf jeden fall zum teil und
zuverlässig das hat auch die
terminplanung manchmal ein bisschen
erschwert dass sie dann ja dann es ist
einfach kurz vorher noch mal irgendwohin
feiern gefahren oder hat er heute
irgendwelche anderen sachen zu tun dass
wahrheit beim interview auch oder bei
den interviews auf jeden fall eine
herausforderung also dass sie dass sie
oft einfach dann so von einem zum
nächsten gesprungen man sagt den neben
den iwata hat ganz kurz dazu haben wir
jetzt noch mal eine frage oder das
wollen wir gerne noch mal genauer und
noch ein bisschen näher
ich glaube auch dass manchmal menschen
wenn sie zu emotionalen dingen zu sich
befragt werden dass sie dann eigentlich
gerne zum nächsten thema springen wollen
wenn sie dann sich darauf einlasse
wusste was man wo es jetzt eigentlich
hin sind gehen so etwas gerade thema ist
dann hat sie auch nicht darauf
eingestellt und mitgemacht und dann auch
relativ schnell tatsächlich auch das
wieder so erzählt wie sie es denn für
sich auch empfunden oder gedacht hat
wenn sie dann irgendwann wann auch immer
mal aus dem knast raus kommt wie stehen
denn die chancen für sie überhaupt noch
mal in die normale gesellschaft
zurückzukehren
also ich bin da bei dem psychologen weil
sebastian bartoschek der das ganz gut
oder auch so zusammengefasst hat dass er
sagt sie hat er nie in normalen also
strukturen gelebt also sie hat keinen
kein geordnetes leben in dem sinne dass
sie mw dann wieder in einem beruf
zurückkehren kann
ich wüsste gerne wie die über all das in
zehn jahren denkt also wie sie dann auf
die zeit zurück guckt ob sie dann nicht
vielleicht doch irgendwie merken
ein bisschen was vorgemacht oder ich
mich irgendwie vom propaganda leiten
lassen oder einholen lassen weil sie hat
ja auch wenn man es schwer fällt das zu
glauben aber das war auch meine
wahrnehmung bei den treffen die wärme
sie hatten durchaus ansätze dazu zu
reflektieren also sie hat uns ja auch
erzählt dass sie irgendwie nachdem sie
zurückgekommen ist kurz vor allem der
block zweiten oder dritten treffen dass
sie bei einer therapeutin war und dass
sie da also suchte er hilfe und sie weiß
dass irgendwas nicht ganz richtig ist
und dass sie das auch nicht von sich
allein aus irgendwie lösen kann auch mit
all den schwierigkeiten was all das was
sie dort gesehen und erlebt hat mit sich
bringt also da sind ja so ansätze da und
deswegen denke ich also genau deswegen
bin ich wirklich gespannt und würde gern
in zehn jahren wieder treffen und sein
weißt du noch was du damals gesagt hast
guck mal ich zeige es hier noch mal kurz
was denkst du jetzt darüber weil ich
glaube dass die schon ansätze hat dass
ich da was verändern könnte aber das
glaube ich auch als ich sieben was ich
gesagt habe als ich zuerst mal mit ihr
gesprochen haben sie noch ein paar 2016
dann war dass dabei der
reflexionsprozess noch nicht so weit
fortgeschritten
das mag in der dokumentation mitunter
bisschen enttäuschend wenn sie wenn sie
da über sachen spricht dann zwar schön
im kalifat das ist tatsächlich ihre ihre
wahrnehmung gewesen was aber glaube ich
eher auf großreich darüber ist
mehr aufschluss darüber gibt wie es ihr
in deutschland ergangen ist wenn sie das
als schön empfindet an kriegsgebiet zu
gehen und sich dann da ja welche tiere
zu kümmern und da irgendwie sich eine
heile welt zumindest vorzugaukeln
und es ist hier mindestens halb bewusst
dass es eben auch nur dass sie sich dann
die ganze zeit schon was vorgemacht hat
nämlich dann wenn man wenn man darauf
achtet wie sie über die über die ehe mit
ihrem mann spricht sie fängt an zu
weinen wenn sie überlegen wenn den tod
spricht und über den verlust und so
weiter erzählt dann aber auch an anderer
stelle dass die er offensichtlich gar
nicht so glücklich war sie hat sich auch
scheiden lassen also das ist das ist ein
reflexionsprozess der bei ihr der glaube
ich lange dauern wird und der werde wenn
er professionell begleitet wird
dann hoffentlich irgendwann in zehn
jahren erfolgreich ihr habt ein halbes
jahr daran gearbeitet ihr wart sehr nah
dran wie habt ihr die ersten stunden und
tage nach der veröffentlichung der doku
erlebt also ich habe direkt noch am
abend der veröffentlichung bin ich nach
hause es war spät abends sondern etwas
anstrengender tag auch in die badewanne
gegangen und hat direkten anruf von
einer kollegin bekommen die gesagt hat
aber ich habe die doku sehen ich habe
ganz viele fragen dazu
20 minuten lang telefoniert und es ging
tatsächlich auch weiter also dass sowohl
im kollegen umfeld als auch im privaten
umfeld noch also ich bin noch nie so
viel rückmeldung auf eine geschichte
bekommen und ganz viele leute halt
fragen hatten die sich mit denen auch
decken die die leute unter den in dem
trailer bei youtube haben also das was
stimmt mit der nicht ist die naiv hat
die geld dafür bekommen warum gehen wir
da so eine plattform also man hat
gemerkt dass das thema erstens
interessiert aber auch total
polarisieren
ich möchte nicht mehr ob ich die fahne
gegangen bin oder keine ahnung was ich
dann an dem tag also ich weiß nicht mehr
was ich an dem tag gemacht habe aber ich
habe noch ich weiß auch dass das man
viel rückmeldung bekommen hat von
kollegen von von anderen von anderen
bekannten die das sich mit dem thema
professionell beschäftigen
und was mir noch in erinnerung ist ist
das war so ein gefühl von erleichterung
dass man das projekt jetzt abgeschlossen
hat und jetzt mal mit etwas abstand
gefragt was hat die geschichte mit euch
persönlich also die geschichte der isis
rückkehrerin was hat das mit euch
gemacht also auf jeden fall ist es
wahnsinnig interessant tatsächlich auch
solche einblicke von so jemanden zu
bekommen also der also man geht er dann
so ein bisschen wie mit noch mal auf die
reise mit jemanden einfach durch die
geschichte und was mit mir das auf jeden
fall gemacht hat ist dass mir das
gezeigt hat dass menschen die bei isis
sind oder waren im prinzip jeder zeit
also die könnte das sind menschen die
besitzen mit ihrem café und du weißt es
nicht das ist auf jeden fall ein sehr
merkwürdiges gefühl
ja also ähnlich wie dir also ich fand es
sehr interessant mit jemandem zu über
einen längeren zeitraum zu begleiten der
sich tatsächlich so offen äußert weil
egal wie vertraut die leute sind wenn
sie wenn sie wenn man mit denen im
hintergrund spricht dass jemand vor der
kamera sich so offen äußert dass das war
für mich eine neue erfahrung dass das
hatte ich so noch nicht erlebt also ich
glaube dass das tatsächlich etwas ist
was ja ich bin nicht sagen so einen
pädagogischen ansatz dann auch hat mit
der mit der dokumentation aber es ist
eben doch einen anderen einblick gibt
auf die problematik dass es vielleicht
auch ein größeres den herren endgültig
sagen verständnis aber ein großer und in
den blickwinkel etwas weiter auf diese
problematik auf die auf die tatsache
dass es eben auch leute sind die sich
dort eine terrororganisation
anschließend gehen weil es eben nicht
den man es eben nicht auf den ersten
blick ansieht und die letztendlich in
unserer gesellschaft schon jetzt unter
uns leben wir haben diese diskussion ja
seit ungefähr einem jahr relativ
intensiv vergessen wird dass das es eben
schon hunderte rückkehrer nach
deutschland gibt und die eben hier unter
uns leben und ich hoffe dass das halt
dass diese doku auch diese ja ein
anderes nicht nochmal auf dieser auf
diese rückkehrer diskussion wirft
die komplette video reportage von einem
pauli und björn stritzel die könnt ihr
sehen wenn jetzt dran bleibt wir zeigen
euch den trailer